you mentioned eric wants and people
should listen to your conversation with
eric as a fascinating one is great uh
it's non-standard it just goes all over
the place and there's humor and weight
it's great so one
interesting aspect that i also learned
perhaps not about you but about eric
about both but
eric has a similar thing as with jordan
peterson
which is
if you ask him do they believe in god i
think the answer
they're not comfortable answering that
question or they might say no but
they're usually just not comfortably
answering that question but there's a
kind of sense that
they would like to live life
a religious life as if god exists i
think that's exactly right i think first
of all eric has a really deep
appreciation of the jewish tradition
i don't know peterson i've read his
stuff and i've reviewed his stuff and so
on but i think that
jungians are in their
very approach
they
believe that myth is the way the world
works and so it's not that big a leap to
god but it's still
there's still a distance there is it
possible to have your cake and eat it
too
is it possible to have the depth
of a religious life without believing in
god like how do you make sense of eric
weinstein's
uh devout life within the tradition
i mean i honestly think he believes in
god
but doesn't believe in god and it's
oscillating like it's a quantum
mechanical system of some sort
schrodinger's god um so i think that he
would probably agree with what uh elie
wiesel said that that a jew can
can be angry at god or be disbelieving
of god but is not allowed to be
indifferent to god
and i think eric's not indifferent to
god
and and it's different than christianity
i've had this conversation many times
because you can be
very jewish and have deep doubts
about
theological questions because judaism
isn't a religion it's a religious family
and so you're born jewish like if i said
to you tomorrow if i was christian and i
said oh i believe in jesus today and
then tomorrow i didn't i'm not christian
anymore but if tomorrow i said i don't
believe all this stuff i'm still jewish
so it's a more complicated
system having said that though
i think it's very hard to sustain over
generations without
some belief that the source of it is
beyond ourselves and and in that sense
as in many others eric is unique
well he was actually making that claim
that we need
faith
to uh
propagate
this tradition through the generations
yeah so without that the traditions
crumble it's a very interesting
idea
a very interesting argument for
developed faith which is it's a thing
it's a glue that holds a tradition
together otherwise like traditions fall
apart right so you can't have
the intensity
of that tradition i mean on the other
hand you do see tradition i mean
thanksgiving one of my favorite
so i would say traditions that are
demanding fall apart
to traditions that that require turkey
might not fall apart but traditions that
are that make demands of you that are
counter cultural or are hard they fall
apart i think i need to introduce you to
some thanksgiving dinners that are quite
demanding
getting the family together you know
there's a first of all i'm a vegetarian
so i'm
tough to have at thanksgiving dinner but
there's a there's a comedian named kathy
landsman who one year i heard this on
the radio and it stuck with me she said
that uh that holidays are a chance to
renew your resentments afresh
you know and that's basically what
people do with their families it's like
i'm gonna go home and fight with the
uncle again this year
you